oh the biden's that's that's who joe's
in trouble uh low ratings but well the
economy is in the [ __ ] you know this
i mean you've been a good mood i'm very
glad to see that because stock market
crashed or is crashing uh inflation
off the charts shortages and everything
are we sure it's not russia who's
putting the sanctions on us that's
now
on the bright side with the economy that
guy at the office who will never stop
talking about crypto has stopped talking
about crypt
so
i mean you know the economy is bad when
johnny depp breaks up all the furniture
in a room and then spends the rest of
the night carefully putting it back
together
[Music]
[Applause]
so we
we also had the uh another week of the
hearings about january 6th and uh
i hope that means you're against it but
uh not the hearings january 6. and uh
it's amazing stuff here a lot of it was
about how the kind of pressure that uh
vice president pence at the time was up
against uh on the morning of january 6th
trump called him and said you better do
this for me and penn said he wouldn't
and trump called him a wimp
and a
[ __ ] i cannot wait for the movie
version of this
[Laughter]
when the movie comes out i don't know
who will play mike pence
but there's going to be a scene where
mike pence is like yes
maybe all my life you're right i was a
wimp and a [ __ ]
but not today
you